madrid amaneció teñida de naranja
tejados calles e incluso los vehículos
están cubiertos por una fina capa de
arena del desierto del sahara un
fenómeno llamado calima y que está
afectando a toda la península ibérica en
las islas canarias de sur a norte
impulsada por la borrasca celia que ha
levantado fuertes vientos en el norte de
áfrica pese a lo bonito a lo curioso que
pueda parecer este fenómeno que tiene
ventajas medioambientales ya que esta
arena del desierto trae consigo fósforo
y hierro que fertilizan los suelos este
fenómeno trae consigo también efectos
nocivos como por ejemplo la falta de
visibilidad pero sobre todo el
empeoramiento de la calidad del aire la
agencia estatal de metereología de
españa advierte de que la calidad del
aire en madrid es muy deficiente
mientras que en otras ciudades del sur o
del este de españa la calidad es
extremadamente deficiente por eso las
autoridades recomiendan limitar las
actividades al aire libre y quienes
quieran y opten por ello volverse a
poner la mascarilla en
al aire libre este polvo del desierto
del sahara va a llegar tan al norte de
europa como el noroeste de alemania o
países bajos